consensus in terms of completing is
similar to consensus in terms of humans
if you're a group of friends who's
organizing to go to coffee and you're
trying to pick a time in which to go you
may have some friends that don't reply
some messages might get lost you might
ask a friend to ask another friend they
might forget about it
one friend might be off having a nap and
doesn't reply to your message despite
all of that you still manage to to reach
agreement you seem still managed to
reach consensus between you when we're
talking about consensus we're normally
talking often inside a data center using
the coffee analogy so if you've got a
group of three friends Alice Bob and
Charlie Alice wants to go for coffee
she'll message Bob and Charlie and say
hey guys do you want to go for coffee at
2:00 and if these are nice reliable
friends they'll message back and say yep
great let's do two o'clock and then
Alice will message both Bob and Charlie
to confirm that that time is okay and
that agreement has been reached in
practice however anyone who tried to
organize anything will know that things
aren't that straightforward Alice may
message Bob and Charlie they may respond
and then Alice may confirm with Bob but
she may get distracted maybe she has an
app maybe she's busy in a meeting she
may never confirm with charlie charlie
now doesn't know what's going on Charlie
could try to maybe try to contact Bob
and find out what's going on so you may
have other parties that are trying to
organize things during the day we've got
D for Danny here and Danny may be saying
hey can you come to a meeting at 2:00
but Charlie doesn't know because charlie
is basically blocked until he finds out
sure what's going on with Alice and the
same is true for computer systems if
you've got a bank this has a hundred
pounds on bob has fifty grounds you have
this database and you replicate it
across three different machines then you
have some clients so these might be an
ATM might be a website for online
banking you might have an online
bookstore and then you might have a shop
in a restaurant and these clients will
put in requests and say things like how
much money does Alice have
so this machines could respond and say
Alice has 100 brown spots during this
time another guy let's say Alice wants
to spend 50 pounds we could change it
value here and reduce it 50 and respond
but it would then be inconsistent with
the value here so these three machines
need to communicate in the same way that
Alice Bob and Charlie did to reach
agreement about how much money Alex has
in her bank account so we can look at
Alice requesting to take out 50 pounds
out of an ATM in the same way that we
did this coffee example between Alice
Bob and Charlie so the Machine contacts
the other machines and says how much
money does Alice have these guys respond
let's assume that's back 100 again and
once this machine has got the responses
you could say okay thank you I returned
them as well back importantly these
machines say yes that would be okay
but they don't actually take the money
out of the account at that point in the
same way that when someone says can you
do coffee at 2:00 you don't immediately
put it in your calendar you wait for
them to confirm before you do that so
then this machine once it sees the B
other machines all happy to put this
request through will respond and say
okay put that through all of the
machines would use the money down to 50
and respond to the cash machine to say
that Alice has enough credit to get the
money out of the machine this protocol
is called two-phase commit and it's a
good starting point for a lot of
consensus algorithms it requires each
node to ask another node and come back
so the time it takes to speak to a node
and come back is known as the round-trip
time or RTT because it's a two-phase
commit there's two phases of it it takes
to RT T's to reach consensus in this
situation there are however problems
with it because failures can still occur
for example the node that was doing the
coordination here might fail and it
might not be clear whether these other
guys should take the 50 pounds out or
not that's the worst
where alice asks the cash machine fifty
quid the cash machine says services down
you can't have your fifty quid but the
50 quid goes out of her bank account
anyway what we can do instead is use
free phase commit so this adds an extra
step to the two-phase commit so here the
client comes and says can we deduct
fifty from Alice's bank account the
server asks the other two as before they
respond to say Alice has sufficient
balance sedusa now we add an extra face
this is called the preparer face so this
is where one server tells the others
okay we're ready June's but don't do it
just yet these guys say okay we'll wait
to hear some more for you and then once
the server hears from everybody it
responds and tells everybody hey guys
you can now decrement Alice's money to
fifty this extra stage is important
because if the server who was doing the
coordination was to fail these guys know
that consensus was already reached so
they just have a timer and if they don't
hear from the server who was
coordinating the transaction at the time
they can then apply the transaction
knowing that it was Satan their safety
went through this does have problems
however for example before we talked
about how two-phase commit was two times
the RTT well this protocol now has three
phases so it now takes three times the
rtt to reach consensus and there's some
more problems too here we're assuming
that the network is reliable and that
all these messages get through but in
practice this network might not be
reliable there might be different kinds
of partitions and the nose could
actually fail one of the ways that we
deal with this is we work with what's
called majorities and minorities so if
you have five nodes you do not need to
involve every node in every transaction
the whole reason why we need multiple
machines in the first place is because
you've got tons of traffic being thrown
at these distributed systems like a web
server if there wasn't much traffic we
could just have one machine and this
wouldn't be so much of a problem because
you're going to want to have all this
traffic you don't want every single
machine to be involved in every single
request because you've not made
Oshin actually any better so what we do
instead is say that a majority of nodes
must agree before you go ahead with a
request if you always work with the
majority you get an interesting thing
which is called the majority
intersection property majority
intersection property means that if you
pick any two majorities there will
always be an overlap of at least one
node so we have five nodes here if you
pick three of them which is a majority
you can't make a set of three again
without including at least one node from
the previous set so this means if a
group of three of these nodes decided
that Alice took 50 pounds out and then
you try to take another 70 pounds out of
the bank account at least one of the
nodes that would be involved in a
process must have seen that Alice has
already taken out 50 this is really
useful because it reduces the load on
the service it means you now need almost
half as many servers when you're
processing any one transaction it also
means that if any minority of servers
were to fail you can carry on as you
were before and it also means if you
have a partition which isolates a few of
the notes you can carry on as you were
before even though you have this
partition interfering with things
so a lot of the protocols that we use
nowadays are based on a protocol called
Paxos paxos was invented by a famous
computer scientist called Leslie Lamport
who won the Turing award last year